on est parti avec un tout petit peu
d'avancé histoire de d'avoir deux trois
minutes pour vérifier tout marche et
tout soit au top et après on pourra
tranquillement démarrer notre stream
alors le streaming marche
on va juste récupérer les de chat en
tout cas on va essayer et on va essayer
de faire un peu des mythes ce soir je
pense pas être en grande forme même on
vient voir comment ça se passe on va
voir comment ça se passe
je suis juste et de chat on vérifie que
tout marche bien et on est parti
on est parti en tout cas ici c'est parti
passé il ya des gens qui sont arrivés
je ne crois pas à lyon va se lancer
maintenant mise trois minutes en à ce
qui se passe alors on joue contre eux
autre facteur sns nfs risi sncf ça
craint le mec au rite en retard lemay
corps est en retard ok donc oui j'ai une
trompeuse ce qui joue j'ai ici ce qui
est plutôt photos qui vont voir facteurs
sncf par une première victoire
tranquille
on est très très content très heureux de
cette première partie ça commence plutôt
pas mal et on va lui faire une
scandinave
parce que ça donne séparément
on échange au quai des quatre cavaliers
f6 avec ses 6
les variantes les variantes normal ces
positions théoriques larhantec rock
c'est pas la variante la plus ambitieuse
normalement je vais plutôt avec fu d2 et
qui on essaye de jouer avec grand roque
là du coup généralement ça rentre dans
une position plus ou moins égales jeu
presque et b17 et pas plus précis mais
bon ok tout à fait jouable qui valurent
deux bombes si le mètre carré en g3
pourquoi pas mais tu vas je suis pas sûr
que ce soit un très bon plan parce que
lecavalier pas forcément beaucoup mieux
placés ici et puis comme on n'a pas
encore roque et on va pouvoir jouer avec
h5
alors là on va prendre une fois ici du
coup hockey et on va jouer probablement
fouet f4 du coup ça nous placera bien
notre dame qui est fou des sites aussi
jouable à 107 le bon fou mais ok
pourquoi pas j'ai cinq bons mais la
rigueur qu'avec des cinq on va échanger
en f4 on va faire grand roc ou un petit
rock d'ailleurs du coup si les change
pas les dames on peut avoir un fils
comme idée à un moment donné attention
âge et 6,5 pour pas se faire martyriser
le pion au 6 mai ça peut être une idée
pour échanger ou vers la colonne h est
probable mais surtout faire grand roque
roye b 8 se mettre à l'abri voir ce qui
se passe ok donc maintenant il faut
absolument calculs et puis on fout
pranger trois prises pris 0 f1 ça doit
les rien de rien donné du coup
maintenant qui s'est un petit peu
affaibli j'ai quand même bien dans
l'idée envie de garder mon fou de cases
noires ça quand même quand même bien
qu'il ait dû jouer g 3g pachins sent que
c'est un affaiblissement peut-être un
jour il ya du foot range étroit possible
et du coup du coup pas mal aucun
warocqué comme qu'ils aient un paf pas
se précipiter avec afi surtout quand on
a laissé le fou il y aurait prise prise
éventuellement et vont savoir et la
colonne j'aimais surtout h6 g6 qui
m'embête hockey ou qui vient avec le fou
en d3 iota de jouer ces quatre par la
suite éventuellement possible
voyons quelques baffes
pas 6 landes pour nous car fr qui a et b
4 et surtout et quatre peut-être faire
f5 et du coup surprise on va pouvoir
reprendre 2g avec l'idée d'ouvrir
d'ouvrir une colonne devant le roi en
fait t'es tu préparé cette arrivée tour
g8 et devenir sacrifié en et devenir
sacrifié en g3 qui convoie recul avec
lecavalier il va faire ses quatre et on
n'a plus trop de casse pour notre cavale
parce que si on fait cavalier seul cette
île fessé 5 et il nous enferme le fou ce
qui évidemment je n'avais pas vu ce dont
j'aurais joué de manière différente
du coup et turc a et b ci sont assez
sains et locaux qu'un petit problème de
un petit problème tactique
du coup il faut qu'on a rien pour pour
tout projet 3-2 face on n'a pas trop le
choix dont tour g8
ça nous permet de menacer cavalière cas
d'échec au prêt au passage qui garderait
le cavalier et sur fion prend des cinq
qu'on va faire [ __ ] en g3 on va
peut-être prendre en prenant des cinq
une fois on peut pas vraiment créé à
prendre en g3 et on va espérer mais je
pense que puis on prend aussi ses ultras
pénible perso j'ai pas trop de suite
dans mon attaque
ok puis en france et six dans le même
esprit je dirais
mc comb a pas grand chose à part on n'a
pas eu trop de bol c'est parce qu'on va
prendre quand même ici lutte est donc
airs point que le fou ici
du coup si on prend il va faire tourner
un film en version aschbach avec le roi
sont un pas trop le choix
votre bien prendre 17 du coup laurent
une pièce de plus alors surtout prend f2
prise prise échec le roi s'échappe il ya
absolument rien absolument rien nulle
part
on absolument et c'est prendre cette
sphère d'anne decis comment et quand
même très très mal rockets effet un
échec en premier
rh 5g pas pour essayer de faire h4 mais
bon c'est quoi ton désespéré sens
tellement désespérés qu'ils appliquent
affaire d'âme leucate échec et fo f4
j'ai un peu de mal à le trouver au
quidam des cinq du coup on va se cacher
avec le roi ok bon on résiste encore un
tout petit peu à proposer nul à tours
angers 4 ok maintenant faut f4 ça marche
ok
le temps de s'échauffer on va voir ce
que ça donne et on rejoue on va refaire
des quatre espérant que ça se passe
aussi bien que la bleue la partie
précédent qui secoue g5 sais pas si je
pense qu'il va prendre le fouet et c'est
un peu ridicule du conte mais le fond
fiant qu'eto'o qui peut taper
éventuellement sur bessette et on va
tranquillement jouer donc ces six des 6
1 ces 6 b 7 6 qui permet de contrer le
fou et on va venir essayer de martyriser
l'ale la dame de notre adversaire
enfin rapidement les pièces donc vous
voyez c'est prendre des prononcé six
éventuellement et pour le moment il
protège on va laisser faire un sur alger
âgées admises pas très grave surtout
notre côté si de doubler rapidement les
tours sur la colonne bay est comme ça on
a sera pré vente ul mans de fer pions
prend ok donc ça c'est pas mal fait de
sa part
peut-être switch en étant à tour en d1
on est sûr d'attaquer ses pions avec la
case des cinq cas relief 4 qui est des
cinq aussi éventuellement possible
qui prend
du coup je vais faire qui a aidé 5
intermédiaire en premier il y aura
peut-être dams est ce un coup là je vois
vraiment rien pour le moment très
difficile
ok le voit pas non plus peut-être dame
c5 protéger il y avait foule prend des 4
enfin deux variantes suis pas je pense
que c'est très mal joué de ma part en
premier puis de la part de mon
adversaire mais bon comme on dit est
rare nourrit futé devient un bon coup du
coup c'est peut-être un bon coup donc
avec la dame en b 4 comme ça on va
réattaquer le pion le pion des six sept
caisses comprend d ici six français
quatre on prend bessette vrai j'ai envie
de tenter ça en fait
j'envie temps de ça y est c'est qu'il
prend ici je prends bessette et le fou
se retrouve un peu à court de cases
peut-être peut-être il a encore poussé 8
qui tient tout il faut aussi importante
ou quoi faut ici soit et du cou
et du coup mes idées base marche pas du
tout je suis vraiment désolé pour le
moment je n'arrive pas du tout à
calculer ok on va prendre des limites et
du coup c'est pas mal c'est un bon
entraînement voir comment on joue si on
n'arrive vraiment pas à calculer
alors ici on essaye de sauver
l'essentiel c'est-à-dire le demi point
et puis tu entreprends défaire des cinq
mecs qui arrivent en c3 ou faire des
cinq direct mais les deux me paraissent
assez merdique
ok je voulais apprendre
et on va faire tout re on va laisser fou
des quatre tours prend 2,6 il va prendre
un f2 nom va espérer avoir des espèces
de perpète et des défenses en utilisant
la tour sur la sur la 7e qui permet
d'offrir du contre jeu donc on va voir
mais des sarts entreprendre le 6
rapidement et s'ils jouent avec ses 3
s'arrêter s'est chopé le pion alors ici
où on va prendre et si fait tourner on
va pousser s'il fait trop évident on va
faire food et 5
ok et si pousse on pousse y pousse on
pousse on menace dame en premier et s'il
fait trop d un du coup monde dames
du coup pas mal pour nous qui les
donnent espion parce que même s'ils
saluent pari d'ouvrir la colonne des
tout ça qu'on a le temps de faire
recette
maintenant que tu comprends pas tout ce
que faire ce que si fait tourner on va
faire dame et si fait ça on a fou des
cinq échecs et froides voilà incroyable
incroyable partie c'est du vol
heureusement qu'on n'est pas trop
mauvais en finale parce que ça là on
devait jamais la gagner
c'était vraiment le festival des erreurs
de notre côté hockey dans cette position
non c'est plutôt bien bien tiré on va
dire ça lui a fait chaud paradise
bonsoir bonsoir
ok donc ici comme m je vais faire dan 17
à la base mais cavalli c5 très pénible
qui on peut mettre la dame réussissent
mais je sais pas ça pas une bonne tête
quoique dames 6 a eu l'idée de mettre le
cavalier en d4 après ma foi ça permet de
clouer le cavalier et ça permet de
menaces éventuellement cavaliers des
quatre qui peut être pas mal du tout et
surtout les cinq évidemment je n'y avais
pas pensé
d'ailleurs c'est un peu le seul coup qui
est embêtant c'est du coup sûr fuji et
katia faut prendre ces six
intermédiaires et si je fais cavaliers
6-6-6 va prendre je vais prendre il va
faire des trois c'est assez désagréable
et si je prends je peux prendre en
premier le 4 mai il va faire dame
prendre 4 et je me retrouvais que ce
flou âge
et si je vous fous j'ai 6 900 que je
vais perdre trop de temps
ok aventure en juger si c'est pas mal ça
me permet au moins de gagner un temps de
développement avec fu j'essaie tout en
protégeant le fou du coup on surfe où
pranger dame prend donc ça ça va cavalli
c5 aucun interdit parce qu'il doit à
farouk et son roi et enfin et jusque
louer et du coup si rock
bon je sais pas j'aime pas trop ainsi
rock parce qu'en fait je vais faire
bouger cette de base mais un carré lisse
et 5 et du coup si rob et moi on verra
en impro vide donc d4 aussi assez
désagréable d'ailleurs mieux que je
pense qu'ici on peut jouer avec grand
roque et sur des cinq largué une
calloc'h et quoique même peut-être se
fait qu'elle prend des saints que
j'aurais voulu prendre 4 et ça ira
ok du coup il prend et je prends ici
avec la dame et du coup je me suis pas
doubler les pions et là j'ai envie de
larguer la call of quand même donc ce
coup là on largue une cloche mais je
pense que je récupère déjà un pion et
peut-être même le pion c2 qui tombe dans
la foulée et du cou du coup ses deux
pions pour la qualité c'est très bien
parce que je vais reprendre donc là je
vais changer les dames et je vais
prendre le pion ces deux donc on a deux
pions pour la qualité et une meilleure
structure de pions donc en fait je pense
que c'est complètement à notre avantage
alors ok le petit problème c'est un peu
ce pion nokia va nous pousser
mais si c'est faux c'est un contrat m6
il ya tour c'est un flou f5 a et b 5 qui
me gêne un peu parce qu'après assis sur
la tête qui a valu à cet échec mais ce
n'est pas si grave le roi par et le
cavaly sera mal placé fait c'est si
c'est pour pas un pro vient vous
expliquer c'est pourquoi me retrouver
avec de pression sur sur cette caste et
c'est donc savant dont je parlais je
pense qu'elles essayent juste 3 17 et
finalement même si ça paraît un poil
dangereux je pense c'est plutôt le
cavalier en bout de course qui se
retrouvera enfermé et si fait cavalier
ici jeu juste mettre le fou en dix-sept
fou g7 si je peut regrouper mes pièces
voyez tente le tout pour le tout si je
peux bien regroupée mais pièce ça va
bien se passer au cap est fait autour
des 1 et suroît 8 tête repoussée 7 il
veut rentrer en force mais bon tf6
moi j'ai pas pour le moment mon foot
j'aime bien la case 17 et même s'ils
rentrent par derrière est ce que c'est
si grave en plus sur fou c'est ça je
suis peut-être faire justice ou 17
je continue à soutenir améliora cavalli
ses limites vous 17 qui a hissé 8 et
surtout prend ses huit tours des huit
pattes pénible du coup faut que je joue
f6 c'est peut-être mieux fait retour des
huit tours b 8
ce qui est très étonnant qu'ils aient
pas jouer tourbe et 8 mai en gros dans
tous les cas c'est bien pour lui donc
dommage que je pense on avait pas mal
joué mais on se retrouve dans une
position difficile à cause de cet enjeu
roula et on a plus de temps plus je veux
encore accéléré en train de discuter de
parler d'expliquer et attend les
secondes s'égrènent
mais bon c'est le beau jeu les
explications c'est le bouge avec laurent
aussi son va tenir on va le faire tomber
à l'ancienne les tontons avaient tous
fondés 4g à prendre prendre
donc s reprend 1,5 g roi e6 et ça doit
aller puis à prendre l'air fou c'est 8
du coup je menace ça elle
malheureusement je ne peux pas en fermer
la tour a pas grand chose car je vais
tours 8
ok je vais prendre avec la tour il faut
que je joue plus vite là donc on va pas
se faire mater on va me mettre l'euro
angers 6 allez allez allez il faut
accélérer
enfin il faut accélérer surtout nous qui
devons accélérer pas lui tu doit
ralentir ralenti oui on va tous tenir
on va faire feu de tout bois
qui
ok ok comme dirait jacquouille ah non
mais j'ai un enfant de la guerre
ok ça va le faire ça va le faire bout a
non il voulait faire rager de toute
façon à on a gagné on a gagné c'est
n'importe quoi c'est n'importe quoi
sacrifices c'était vraiment de la grosse
daube
c'était vraiment la grosse d'homme c'est
pas mal sorti salut à tous le monde dans
le chat de check point comme c'était
vraiment de la mauvaise qualité de
partie énormément de chance
est ce qu'une des filles madaghri le
défi mais bon ce soir c'est pas les spas
les parties contrôler pour les
spectateurs on essaye de on essaye de se
battre avec avec d'autres joueurs
mais bon c'est parti a été épique mans
mauvaise contre matt sanofi tx et ses
six salles on va jouer un petit voire
antec bessac boom une espèce de
d'ouverture polonaise mais où on a
attendu que le car alice soit sorti en
f3 ce qui est mieux en fait ça permet
d'avoir rajouté cavaliers fils et
d'empêcher aux blancs de jouer le 4 et
du coup on a une position assez correct
ok car il ya trois peut être un poil
pénible mais vous s'en sortir je vais y
aller parc et à 3 mettre la pression sur
ce pion à faire des six essais 5 d'un
bon contrôle de la case de cas donc ça
c'est plutôt bien
on va jouer avec ces cinq cantons il
joue avec ses 5 juin que 4,1 du coup
mais pas grave
donc il échange massivement il veut me
faire un truc en sortie de variantes ou
pas et ça un peu en panique en région
comme ça qu'ils échangent tout de
manière
comment dire
manière c'était pas le mot que je
l'emploie en premier qui ait changé tout
en jouant très rapidement sur
l'impression qu'il ya une pointe enfin
de mariée en tout un truc
le caire 17 en premier comme ça on verra
se passe je voulais savoir où ils
allaient sortir son fou du coup on va
mettre la dame en b 6 permet de re
protéger le pion comme ça surtout
prendre cavaliers prend on est
tranquille selon était à toulon des huit
après une cavale y en a eu cinq s'initie
au change si par padduc loi j'ai pu
sinon je sais pas peut-être qu'à 24
hockey va peut-être mettre sa dame
enceinte ou pas
un truc j'avais pas envie de faire de
base cck j'avais pas une tournée de le
jouer de base même que peut-être bien et
que saddam en a cinq
j'ai envie de chasser le cavale et puis
comme ça ça damman elle est peut-être un
peu mal placé comme ça je mettrai le
quart ayant ses 5
je suis assez heureux je sais pas j'ai
l'impression de pouvoir fait un jour
venir là rapidement sur quatre ok il
reprend je prends je la perds de fou
maintenant très heureux
damas trois fois que cette dame soit
très bien placé perso même plutôt
l'inversé il peut vouloir faire dame b 4
au prochain pour m'attaquer un peu
du coup je faire re 5 j'ai chassé le
cavalier et je vais mettre ma tour des
huit j'ai parié une colonne ouverte j'ai
envie d'aller dessus ok et ses clients
avec saddam ici je mettrais peut-être le
fond ces six comme ça je défends un peu
je m se font en c6 j'ai un son qui veut
venir m'enquiquiner en fait
alors ça c'est un coup que je ne
comprends pas du tout profité vrai
lecavalier en b3 jeu trésor avec mme
carrier en b3 auquel adam a pas trop de
cases en partant d'ici
du coup je faire dame bessette et je
vais essayer de faire flouer quatre
tours à huit pour essayer de choper
saddam en fait on va essayer de faire un
enfermement de dames les mecs
ok on va on va cacher la tour et on va
aller menacer torah et on coupe comme ça
et je qui a été fou on fait du découpage
ok il défend plus ou moins tout autant à
prendre une fois ici ça fera du débarras
à ya peut-être cavalli praia fouet 4
heureusement du coup il doit reprendre
là on va peut-être faire tours 1 du coup
ils obligés de faire dame prendre ce que
s'il fait d'amis si je fais faire tout
reprend d un prise en d1 et dames 17 et
du coup comme lecavalier plus on est 3
vous voyez il est cloué
et ben voilà ça c'est une belle partie
bien mené du coup si les gens veulent
veulent faire des parties avec avec
bessin qui peut vous donner des idées
c'est une partie sympa ça là pour une
fois petite domination petite domination
au fond de court à la chatte tandis que
les secteurs fc2 de gagner sa dame a
finalement n'a pas nié la dame n'en a
gagné du matos on sentait bien qu'il se
paye à 20 pro-laïcs cette dame là alors
on va jouer cette petite variante
pas forcément ce cadre mieux
ok on va faire fouetter trois cavaliers
de rock et quart et du coup cahier des
deux cavalières 3 du coup aux 6 5 il a
joué 50 de temps on va quand même faire
f 4 on va installer un gros centre du
coup voilà il prendre reprend on a quand
même trois pions enfin deux pions
centraux est un pion comme sa semi
centrale on va dire ça comme ça
on a beaucoup de cavaliers je met le
pion aux cinq comme ça fera un espèce de
double emploi le fou qui la fout sur une
couleur et les pions sur le sur l'autre
ok comme il attaqué mon chouchou ni en
b3 et ça le savez le point positif
d'avoir fou pranger 6 / rock donc et
comme il prend 1 2 je reprends du fou
parce que j'ai envie de ramener mon
carré les verts eux quatre ok mais s'ils
jouent comme ça je vais faire f 5
on va on va y aller à la brutale des
gens on va y aller à la brutale de chez
brutale on veut faire f6 occuperont va
prendre avec la tour on va ramener le
tour en f1 on va les taper le pion à vii
est ce qui fait qu à es17 on va taper 17
et 6 fait cavalier à 6 on va taper à 6
et on a aussi l'idée flash c'est ok
alors là alors là les petits
alors là les petits ça donne envie de
faire un truc que je vous conseille pas
de faire en partie puisqu'à peut-être
juste tour f1 qui gagne tranquille mais
ce d'y aller à l'ebu on y va gaiement
bout on va prendre ça je les prends en
bessin qu'au début mais on apprend des 5
reprend des allées on va on va aller on
va les regarder un petit peu cette tour
en a huit qui a du mal à se développer
on va juste aller prendre ça du coup est
ok il fait une espèce de double attaque
mais on va faire une double défense on
défend toutes nos pièces et normalement
c'est fini un cavalier se sont va juste
faire t5
on va pousser en force ou fou prend b5
même et les prochains coups c'est juste
tour est fait un flash 5 fprov 7
ok peut-être fou bessin peut-être dame
prend des cartes non à faire des cinq
premières la première attention
[Musique]
donc et on continue le festival bundhoo
reprend f 7 avec 6 fourchette
on y va en force on y va en force on
prend des risques à 800 mhz allemand
attendait pour ses tactiques là et là du
coup on va prendre en d5 prendre un set
et prenant b5
donc résultat des courses deux pions une
qualité de plus petite finale tranquille
où est allé abcès banier c'était propre
c'était propre
c'était du propre
ouais on va les chercher un autre
adversaire mais deux parties sympa ça là
allez on joue contre krassimir brockhoff
faire des quatre caves 6 1 comme ça
super kf seront refaits d'un truc à une
baie 5 voilà pouvoir rejouer la même
bon voilà du coup ci donne le point 4 en
fait on est assez heureux de base parce
que c'est un pion central on échange on
échange du coup un pion eux contre un
tube et donc normalement on est quand
même assez content de faire ce genre des
changes et maintenant on va pas on va
pas mettre le pion dessein car on va
garder on va garder la diagonale du fou
ouverte qu'elle joue avec des six sur de
mettre un pion elle construit quelques
cases centrale peut-être du joual 6
avant pour repousser le foulkes pas très
grave
tours 8 avec le fois je suis tranquille
qui veut échanger des pièces du conte va
échanger ainsi tué échangé en échange
est comme ça enfin deux variantes on va
faire ses 5
ça nous permet de pas ne pas bloquer
notre fou auquel le cavaliere f6 on va
protéger notre pions on va échanger ça
ok faire gaffe cas ici si tu fais me le
prendre
les coûts de base n'avait pas très envie
de faire tour ses huit mais il faut bien
que tu passes sûr qu'on est super bien
joué mais du coup à se libérer par des 5
c'est pas du tout la première intention
mais bon je vais comme ça mais du coup
on va profiter un petit peu un d'avoir
cette petite activité pour pour venir
contrer le centre ce que sur le tchad
des gens qui parlent parlent anglais qui
ne parlent pas d'autres langues des
américains sur une chaise point comme
sur le chat de twitch c'est un petit peu
mort alors on va prendre des cinq croit
pas du tout reprendre cette marche j'ai
même pas calculer mais j'y croyais pas
une seule seconde
c'est qu'il propose des changes des
dames
de base va super envie mais ce que j'ai
vraiment le choix en fait à charge
fenêtre la dame en bessette et est
essayé après de jouer avec eux si ce bon
allez on va tenter un diamant bessette
puisqu'elle est sur une feinte ray sur
la diagonale pas mal placé et puis elle
couve la 7e ou le pion à c'est peut-être
le pion b3 pour ça que j'ai mis sur
cette case il ya aussi b 5 mai sur
bessin expliqué j'avais peut-être me
prendre quelque chose qui se frotte âge
le pion de sa est aussi qu'on va faire
si son va se débarrasser de tous les
problèmes sur le but russe est du coup
on rend ces pièces un petit peu on va
pas dire stupide qu'elles sont pas mal
placé mais du coup on a quand même envie
d'un petit peu a su procéder à ce que
les rangs je suis assez content qu'il
ait pris ça parce que du coup je reste
avec mon fou qui est assez bien placé au
kilomètre matou rang des huit donc les
tours sur les colonnes ouverte et ce qui
fait assez plaisir pour moi pour le
moment c'est vraiment ces deux tours qui
sont pas super bien placé
alors il pouvait pas faire grand-chose
de base
donc il veut ramener son calvaire c4
quand même
j'emprunte calculé jean reprise prise
prise prise prise prise échec et dams et
ouais ça quand même la tête du truc
qu'il faut faire ça quand même la tête
du truc qu'il faut jouer parce que du
coup on joue sur ce clou âge ok damev
car jusque là j'ai vu
et surtout re 1 il veut faire tours 4
il veut faire tour 4 et sur cinq il va
juste rester au contact de sa tour et ça
va être nul qui aurait quand même faire
et malheureusement on n'a absolument
rien
ok on va quand même tenté un le beau jeu
on va mettre la tour on va ramener la
dame ans et on va essayer d'y aller à
akwa que hockey / f 5 e 4 non ça parle
ou là on a plus de temps c'est n'importe
quoi ce que je fais
après c'est le beau jeu hein mais c'est
surtout des bilans fait surtout qu'on
risque de se faire mater je pense qu
elles furent d'amex en premier mais bon
ok on va on regarde on a fait n'importe
quoi rien faire du tout juste se faire
mater comme des débiles
bon ok j'ai pas vu le temps surtout je
vis de regarder ma pendule
dommage qu'on a tenté ce qu'il fallait
tenter mais c'est pas passé
cependant il réussit pas à s'en sortir
piémont j'essaye de naviguer comme je
peux et je pense qu'il ya h 4 tout
simplement aidé à me 3 et matteo qui
endommagent pas joué assez vite mais
tentez le beau jeu est ici c'est
peut-être quelque chose allez on va
réessayer
on trouve sur une personne qui rejoue du
coup cette même variante il devra
remettre le fou en g2
par mètre carré y en a eu deux on va
tranquillement de nouveau mené notre
attaque allait l'allèle dame de la même
manière un jeu assez clair
alors faire exactement la même chose
rare comment ils jouent apparemment se
casser la tête
on va laisser notre adversaire se casser
la tête le cas du coup ci il provoque
les changes on va le faire s'il fait fou
prend on va peut-être faire qui est des
cinq aya vous prend 1,4 à yakhya il
prend des cinq à madame qui a attaqué
mais qu'est-ce que je suis supp id
non mais c'est juste dingue fait pas
assez concentré je suis pas assez
concentré du coup bah je sais pas
pourquoi j'ai pas fait vous prend ses 6
face à lui sinon aïe aïe aïe il faut
quand même un peu se concentraient aux
échecs beaucoup trop tranquille mais
vous savez partie par alger de bien
commenter mais laisse des petites
erreurs comme ça on va essayer de jouer
malgré la ps2 - évidemment
alors
comment est-ce qu'on peut essayer de
faire quelque chose alors sur tourbe et
si je pense pas on va peut-être mettre
la tour ans et 7
je vais peut-être mettre le cavalier 1,8
m la tour ans et si je sais pas
peut-être qu'il sera pas très bien placé
normalement on peut rien faire est ok
quelques petits coups à trouver pour lui
peut-être donc et venir s'en prendre à
nous
qui a aidé 4b un fouet fin voyage
jusqu'à lyon des 4 au pire on mettra le
fou en f1 on jouera peut-être à y croire
j'ai 2
que jésus est l'atout rang à sept ce que
je veux garder la case c6 pour le pour
le cavale
écoutons berens a fait refoulé fait
enrager 2 tranquille vous pourrez faire
rager de et on essaie comme ça de chars
sont tombés c'était pas super bien
encore une fois on est tellement perdant
que c'est pas très grave pour lui et
quand même alors il veut faire
[Musique]
ok il veut faire sur qui on prend il
veut faire échec et fourrages 3 mais ok
ça me paraît tout ça un peu un peu trop
tactique il veut gagner en jouant de
manière très tactique
ce qui pourrait faire [ __ ] en d4 en
fait depuis tout à l'heure
puis c'est la foudre en d4 depuis tout à
l'heure
alors à quand les quatre filières très
pénible nous dit qu'on avait peut-être
mettre le fougueux 4 ça me permet
d'empêcher tour b1 et sylvie en b2 du
coup on fera peut-être fois à 8o qu'il
prend on prend de façon sans obliger va
reprendre ici c'est sûr malheureusement
ce final est complètement de courir je
sais même pas pourquoi je pense pouvoir
faire illusion en fait ce que la finale
est vraiment pourri peut juste faire
genre vous prend et cavaliers si c'est
fou bessette et je crois qu'on peut
absolument plus rien faire non qu'est
comme je vous dis les seuils de ils
essayent de gagner en prenant quand vous
dire si si je vous dis que sa technique
est pas super propre c'est parce que
j'ai l'impression qu'ils essayent de
faim il fait parler de tactique en fait
ce que j'ai dit alors que nous on a fait
il fallait pas faire ce qu'on faisait le
beau jeu c'est exactement ce qu'il est
en train de faire là donc peut-être fait
le beau jeu ce qui fait inscrire mon but
car enfin tout à fait possible juste
qu'il aime le beau jeu mais en gros il
prend des risques maintenant et
peut-être tours à huit qui va traîner ou
je sais pas vrai ce qui peut arriver
c'est un homme très envie de faire
cavalier b3 perso pour venir attaquer
son fou je garde maximum de pièces sur
l'échiquier la position se complique de
plus en plus et il a moins en moins de
temps et que surtout ses 8 maintenant
j'ai peut-être tour à 8
ok il prend ici mais du coup il me rend
une pièce et du coup il est plus du tout
gagnant ici alors là bas du cou a poussé
ses seins qui va prendre la poussée des
6 et on va venir enfoncé le cavale
enfonceur de portes menace 17
et puis on prend 1,8 bah du coup 17
quand même et on va gagner bah du coup
le final assez sympa 1 2 finale je
dirais c'est répétition mais ok avec une
pièce de moins vous voyez qu'on peut
même contre des joueurs assez fort
finalement puisque 2003 sur ce point
comme c'est quand même pas mal du tout
et on peut réussir à simplement aller à
les battre a malgré la pièce de moins d
un an juste un bon jeu de pièces et même
en calculant comme des idiots
on peut quand même réussir on peut quand
même réussir à faire quelque chose alors
on va tenter avec ses 5 de jouer cette
fois ci on va tout de suite mais c'est
tout de suite lui enlever tous ses pions
sans trop en fait
ok il pousse ses pions
du coup j'ai quand même joué et que j'ai
ici c'est je met donc cavalier en d6
mais j'ai l'impression que j'avais peur
de dan des cats c'est pour ça que j'ai
fait cette petite grimace parce qu'il ya
juste lui en prend donc et du coup on va
placer nos pièces tranquillement et pas
probablement pas formé de à cause de fou
prend des six mais maintenant la soupe
combes et 2 on va prendre ce pas si
grave pour voir ses pions doublé parce
que j'ai quand même ce fou qui est très
fort et puis pas si facile que ça de
venir les attaques et ça prend du temps
bref sept cavaliers de d2 ici qui serait
pas mal joué ok protège pour le moment
alors ce cavalier faut bien le sortir
donc pour le sortir ya pas dix mille
issue avec ac 7
mais c'est une bonne case c'est une
bonne qu'à se permet de ré attaquer le
pion ok donc ici on peut pas prendre b2
puisqu'il ya le fou qui
être en prise donc on va mettre la tour
en b 8 mai ok on est face à un problème
et le problème c'est que ces pièces là
elle ne bouge plus et ça c'est un peu
pénible on va faire f 500 va un peu
empêché aux pièces blanches de
s'approcher je pense que l'hiver tourbe
est un haut lieu de devenir sacrifier sa
qualité
on veut faire dame f6 et essayer en fait
de redévelopper la tour mais là c'est
vraiment un gros problème en fait se
fout ce fou surtout parce que je vois
pas trop d'issue pour lui en fait tant
qu on va remettre la tour ici comme ça
va mettre tours 8
tant va échanger une paire de tours en
fait on ne peut pas sortir se fout il
est complètement enfermé du coup
intéressant encore comme parti envoie on
voit des positions un peu un peu
original un peu différente
et du coup on voit des idées aussi un
petit peu différent donc c'est
intéressant
c'est intéressant de voir des thèmes
stratégiques comme ça qu'on a pas
l'habitude de voir ça permet de
comprendre des choses des choses
différentes siècle à l'enfermement de ce
fou assez intéressant aussi franchement
je vais reprendre du cavale et je vais
essayer d'aller vers eux quatre ok ce
que je vais faire ce kil jacquet à 6 je
veux remettre ce cayambe cas du cifa
trois peut-être que maintenant ça ça
devient une cible
du coup je vais revenir ans et 7 mais
peut-être qu'il a un poil affaibli un
pion je suis pas vraiment si ça veut
dire grand chose mais peut-être que je
peux l'attaqué du coup si je gagne ce
pion à prayssas libermont fou bloquer
cet échec c'est pas grave je m le ranger
cette cavalière pas forcément trop
d'avenir ici on le fout je le mette en
assises de toute façon ça empêchera
toujours qui a et b 5 sera toujours plus
utile mais bon même si je fais tourbe et
8 en fait ça mène pas à grand chose
s'il ya juste faire roi ses deux pouces
et 2 du coup ça défend assez facilement
ok on va mettre le cavalier vérifient
s'ils proposent ni bon ben là de façon
va pas accepter on est là pour la jouer
ok on va prendre quelqu'un russia tous
écrits cac et prend des cinq au bon
moment et je suis pense aussi mais le
problème c'est qu'il a blindé il a
blindé la case mais ok pour le monde
commence à tourner tournicoti
tournicoton va devoir mettre le cavalier
e 2 on va remettre la tour e 8 bon c'est
nous qui jouons peut-être 6 3 roues hk
dollars un moment donné vos qui
reviennent ici chaque élève 6 qui c'est
qui et prend des cinq à un moment donné
3 6 3 5 pour aller s'en prend bastion la
cif et g3 prise d'assaut de choses ok on
va faire 3 h 6 quand même le roi qui
monte ça peut pas faire de mal qu'il va
remettre ça la façon lui c'est pas grand
chose en un point de vue offensif va
remettre le fonds bso a peut-être joué à
cinq passants que j'aime pas trop dans
le sens et affaiblissant mais bon quand
même le faire puisqu'on menaça cadre du
coup il va peut-être être obligé de
faire à quatre saisons ce qui fait qu'à
tuera pas de case pour le cavalier pour
venir on va faire ça va peut-être mettre
la tour en bkt menaces et qu'elle prend
des cinq à un moment donné voilà on va
venir comme ça mais c'est une multiplier
les idées des menaces
on va revenir ici je sais pas j'aime pas
trop on va pas sacrifier pour le moment
on va venir jouer avec 1,6 g 5 plutôt
qu' on va tenter une fois avec cavaliers
h5
alors m la tour en huit
qui ont échangé une fois
nrj avec archi ce g5 à peut-être me
faire droit aux cinq aussi ok on voit
cinq une fois
peut pas réussir à faire quoi que ce
soit
on ne réussit pas rentrer
longtemps on fait vraiment le maximum
on prend les atours
ce qui ce fait 3 3 je vais tenter le
tout pour le tout ou pas
ça n'a pas marché
j'améliore un peu ce fou
pour les prononcé quatre dans le bon
tempo mais on a plus de temps ok je
pense à un peu progressé c'est peut-être
pas assez mais on essaye on tente le
beau jeu à il a fini par craquer il a
fini par craquer
sur saint just can't you like 500 cas du
lac de partout même à pousser les pions
on va encaisser de fou on va gagner
cette partie
c'était pas beau c'est pas beau fini par
l'emporter mais on aura un accueil mis
la pression à tenter de partout
finalement il a fini par craquer il a
fini par craquer c'est pas forcément
très beau mais ok
du coup ça devra pas la première à
lanzhou qu'on te mettre fi des ailes aux
icônes de norvège se passe pas ma nuque
par magnus un norvégien
jusqu'où on va refaire à trompeuse cyr
seul et trompe aussi service volée
trompe costil
petite variante
on va réussir à faire ces 4 4
on va faire ses quatre en fait ce qui se
passe c'est que on va vraiment réussir à
mettre le pion aux quatre normalement
assez rapidement et ça ça va être génial
messi fait cavalier ici on peut
peut-être faire même c5 et son cavalier
va super super mal placé et quand tu
comme ça du coup eu quatre gardiens
tempo sur le fou et cavaliers prend ses
4 et du coup en fait on a bien obtenu
notre gros centre on a obtenu notre gros
centre on n'a même pas de problème de
développement fait ça je suis très très
bien développés dame b3 au prochain on
va taper ici on est très très bien on a
tous développé affaire qui à eux deux en
premier comme ça sur damas cinq échecs
on aura cavaliers c3 tranquillou et on
est super bien développés on a peut-être
même cavalier f4 dans l'est dans les
cartons du coup la bande à développer
toutes nos pièces on est très heureux on
warocqué on a rockets j'en ai une très
bonne position à la sortie de
l'ouverture avec laquelle il va falloir
un peu beau c'est maintenant qu'elles 5
je trouve c'est plutôt intéressant de la
part de notre adversaire il essaye de
s'activer et on aurait peut-être dû
essayé de l'en empêchèrent mais bon
comme je visais aujourd'hui c'est pas le
pas la forme optimale aux quêtes en
vidéo avec fief de saab éviter les
problèmes d'échec et puis ça va replacer
ce fou quand h4 ne paraît pas très bien
placé
quoiqu'une contrôler des limites quand
même nous pas forcément un bon coup ce
coup de feu peut-être trois chiens
étaient mieux ok mais là je pense que tu
exagères tonton tu vas faire des cinq on
va fermer sa cavalière justice ok mais
là je pense qu'il exagère un peu tonton
les dames b3 on va sortir de ce clouage
désagréable on a sept pions prend effet
au 1er set d'ailleurs au passage
et si prend du coup on est très heureux
on va faire payer prend des saints qui à
terme on installera le fou en d5 qui
tapera sur la case b71 chose je pense
qu'il a existé un mauvais comme s'il
fallait faire pousser 5 quelque chose
peut-être même poussé 5 maintenant mais
c'est un peu tard parce que je vais rien
toucher et quand il prendra je prendrai
avec la tour et j'aurais éventuellement
aller tour sur sur les deux rangées
donc elle uk prend est très très bien en
fait voilà prise ce que je disais en
fait se font des cinq super bien passé
c'est un monstre
j'ai les deux fous la dame
éventuellement les tours qui tape sur le
roi donc normalement si je fais pas
n'importe quoi ça doit être plus ou
moins fini même s'ils résistent encore
pas mal je pensais juste à retour c'est
un tour c'est 5
mais non pascal fou qu'il défend du coup
on va faire tour c'est un texte est là
et on sait 4 non tu peux pas faire tour
c'est 7 à cause de dame prend bessette
et on sait 4 en fait avec la menace tour
à 4 vous prend à 7
j'éprouve à utiliser le fouet avec
l'idée aussi est vide et évidemment de
de doubler les tours sur la colonne c
j'aurais très bien pu prendre la torah
aussi pour le faire je sais pas pourquoi
je préfère la tour f
mais du coup il menace assez forte quand
même tour à 4 dps 1 qui défend
étonnant ce coup défensif plein de
moyens de continuer
tout cas pas toujours à 4 sort un jeu
qui ont un fils faire pousser 6 je pense
qu'il ya pas tour d un heureusement mais
du coup on vient sa tour
d'incroyables sur foutront bessaih que
faire pions france et 4 hallucinant sa
défense
mais j'ai juste envie de laisser faire
sa défense ça marche peut-être mais j'ai
juste envie de voir ce qui se passe
après tourné en fait ce que je veux dire
c'est assez bout ce qu'il a fait mais
juste d'un point de vue intellectuel
samsam intéressant s'il peut juste quand
même défendre ça parce que sa défense
vraiment jolie vraiment esthétique mais
quand même ça me paraît pas possible de
défendre kheddam b5
j'aurais pas tour 17 à cause d'eux à
cause de l'échec là bas roland ça défend
quand même son truc moi je dis chapeau à
l'adversaire qui mérite
il mérite de la gagner au cas où son
truc défend quand même ok là il ya une
nulle
ok je veux pas prendre l'avion à faire
flouer trois jeux pour apprendre la
nulle l'idée c'est de faire tour 17 et
sur food et 6e dan des cinq dames prend
des six mais c'est juste marre on fait
de voir ce que ça se défendre ce que
visuellement c'est chaud quoi ok tour 17
maintenant hélas du coup maintenant il
ya plus d'âme c'est le fou défend et le
fou attaqué le pion à cette normalement
il ya tout qui tombe
ok peut-être faire un truc du truc tour
ses huit ok mais là y'a dam des cinq
échecs il faut prendre à cette vente
boum boum boum boum très intéressant
serait intéressant au regard avec l'ordi
pour assiter correct et la comprend à
cette moto prochain va-t-il le voir ou
pas enfin plutôt allez vous le voir ou
pas parce que lui soient soumis à qui le
web assurée en fait voilà et du coup du
coup on va être comme ça
du coup sympa mais je suis vraiment
curieux sans risque que cette position
c'est quelqu'un qui est dans le tchat
s'il ya quelqu'un qui est dans le chat
c'est très très très fâché très que ça
voir ce que donne cette position
objectivement en fait parce que dams et
7 rbds et 5 ça et chaque échec où on est
mieux là ils font ou trois essais juste
intéressant fait juste pour pas sentir
l'activité comment commence à ce qu'en
fait il peut pas vraiment faire dame b 7
ce qui à tour b 8 en fait sur plus ou
moins tous les coups dams façon est un
échec ou une merde il est obligé de
jouer le fouet en fait il a que sept
comme développement ce que sur des sites
je répète rien juste d'amener 5 et dame
prend des 6es du coup on n'a qu'à une
finale avec un pion de plus ses
meilleures activités et doué la pâte
d'autres coups de fou et je pense qu'il
a pas tous en fait très intéressant
l'application 10 dames 8 échecs mais sur
dame huit choix
leroy b cet arrêt est tombé c'est toi
qui étais plus fort saganne y est vrai
bien vu j'ai pas juste j'ai juste pas vu
mais du coup pas vu mais fou et 3 gagne
aussi nu et du coup ici je pensais être
gagnant fait bizarrement tour des 1
et menaces sur 17 en fait ils peuvent
juste rien faire
du coup sympa comme parti
allez on joue contre chuck mais quand un
front qui vend des bouquins allez on va
jouer cette finale contre chelsea chapin
un magazine finale ont vu une finale on
va pas refuser de jouer une finale
contre sienne chez stop par le sénat qui
n'est pas forcément beaucoup mieux pour
les blancs a d'ailleurs mais bon ça se
tient avec les noirs cette histoire
du coup allez on va doubler
j'aurais dû jouer avec 4,4 plutôt je
fais de la merde là bas je fais
n'importe quoi va je suis très énervé
après moi même [ __ ] mais c'est ouf de
jouer aussi mal
ok on va on va solidifier notre truc
parce qu'on fait n'importe quoi on va
remettre qu'à lancer en d3 verser 5 on
va replacer nos pièces de 10 pouces les
pions on peut ignorer ce qui se passe de
l'autre côté de façon il faut qu'on il
faut qu'on se replacent correctement
halal dame
du coup on a fait un bon placement l'a
d'ailleurs très content sur la photo
avec ses livres en tout cas on est très
heureux
g est le cas on sait 3,6 pouces on va
prendre avec lequel on b5 je suis assez
content de ce que j'ai fait oh ça
j'avais pas vu évidemment qui en obligé
de prendre action avec laurent a deux
bons mais c'est pas si grave on va
prendre avec le pion et de toute façon
on contrôle bien les cases
ça va ça va c'est pas la fin du monde
mais bien vite les c4 et on va prendre
magique et en a 4 ans pas on va pas le
laisser venir en c5 ni rien d'autre qu
on couvre pas mal de cases importante
avec le cavalier on y vient de l'autre
côté avec la tour on va devoir un peu
défendre
ok mais mon intuition me dit qu'il faut
que j'aille avec tourbe et un tour b 5
mais j'en sais rien vale ont reçu notre
intuition mais il joue actifs
je vais taper sanctions et puis on verra
après
en fait j'ai même pas j'ai l'impression
que c'est complètement débile tout ce
que je suis en train de faire
on va remettre le cahier verser 4 et on
va mettre la tour en bd on va défendre
chèrement son que ce c'est cette partie
sous le signe de ligne aussi
ce
je comprends rien ses coûts en fait ça
m'énerve
rien ce qui fait ça me ça m'agace
d'ailleurs la question c'est pourquoi
est-ce que j'ai joués ce coup de fouet
en fait je ne comprends rien je ne
comprends pas les profs vider mon fils
n'était pas attaqué pourquoi je suis
allé déplacer mon fou c'est complètement
stupide c'est complètement stupide j'ai
perdu les pédales pour le grand bain qui
va faire pousser 5 qui est fait tous
âges 2 ok bah je vais je vais m en fous
en g3 très très mauvaise partie de ma
part mais font g3 suis très heureux à
miers free asia tour prend des trois que
j'ai pas vu mais je ne vois rien là à
ces affreux un safran c'est vraiment the
bargain quoi
[ __ ]
bon allez c'est dans ces parties là
qu'il faut
qu'il faut sauver
c'est très très mauvaise partie
afflige amant mauvais
de la grosse merde à aller on va aller
s'activer comme on peut
mais quand celui-ci joue pas très bien
enfin suis pas mais il m'a mis en pl ace
en fait j'aime son qui joue pas des
supers bons coups il fait donc pas l'air
d'être en très grosse fort non plus
cavalier prendre son pion
on va tenter de défendre sa main c'était
déjà défendable
comme mon ami entraîneur a mis entre
leurs murs tu as des fois le plus
important c'est pas les parties qu on
gagne c'est les partis qui ont réussi à
ne pas perdre ça peut être une partie
qu'on peut sauver éventuellement par un
tour de magie
on va prendre ça siffle 3 c'est bon s'il
fait des trois je crois que c'est bon
aussi
je crois que je peux défendre ça en fait
ok mais là c'est bon sur des deux
j'encaisse sur e3 j'encaisse le cam et
j'encaisse et veux pas me mettre en
route donc c'est pas possible
l'ess j'encaisse bon je suis content de
cette nulle 37 jusque très mauvaise
partie très très très très très très
très très mal joué et finalement on s'en
est sorti
donc du coup très heureux
très heureux de cet îlot qu'elle a du
coup très heureux de l'ouverture un
nouveau avait un double fiant qui est au
col dégage une nouvelle fois personne ne
sait vraiment à réfuter d'un truc avec
ps5
normalement ça vous prend à y avez-vous
projet agit du raté un truc j'en sais
rien alors je te le g7 auquel je fais à
6 je sais pas j'ai l'impression d'être
en pls constante
ça va je vais faire des 6 et 5 et ça va
aller je suis kébé 5
allez on va revenir en fait ils et b5
hamas vient de bessens que c'est assez
simple je veux contrôler ces quatre pour
l'empêcher de faire ces quatre et je
veux rapidement je vais fouler cette
pelouse chedjou et quatre en fait du
coup je veux contrôler les deux cases
importante de l'échiquier
jouer dams et 8 du coup je protège mon
fou et je veux faire c'est 5 rapidos
ok je vais prendre et rockets même si
vite c'est probablement pas très bon
c'est pas la tête d'un beaucoup de
façons tu retombes bekaert j'ai de la
chance qu'ils essaient cissé il ya des
trucs
je pense que je peux envoyer du lourd de
partout je joue le roi je suis des f-5
bout je pense
je suis très très heureux
ok mais ça j'ai vu et ça j'ai pensé aux
jean resseguie l'on ferme sont tous en
fête des chasseurs ok mais là je vais
récupérer mon idée tout à leur paye ses
six cas à cinquième rang bessette
du coup j'ai multiplient mais l'idée tac
tic tac ical tactique altri qui n'a été
ni je prends les blancs tout le temps
très très heureux très heureux avec les
vins
du coup très très bien je vais récupérer
la tour b 7 et après je manquais c'est
le fou toujours à une tournette de plus
dans le cas du coup je prends ça juillet
à saint qui traîne
ok tente de le sauver mais en fait je
fais qu'aller des 6 et je viens leur ré
attaquer avec le cavale du coup il va
tomber puis tout tombe tombe de plus
simple
qui est notamment à vii et puis
quand un tour de plus ces douaniers
je vais aller essayer d'attaquer ses
pions
thual a encaissé du matos encore faire
gaffe quand même car il y avait eu 3 et
toutes les pièces se ramène je sais pas
du des têtes des sites défendre ces
trucs là en vite
quelle fr 5 je profite du fixe puisse
pas faire fou prend pascal pions f2
café ramener la tour
alors complètement gagnant mais je sais
pas on glisse jamais si simple en fait
thür chiant et gagner
il souhaitait toujours chiant à gagner
mais bon ça va on a un peu solidifier et
mal en ce qu'elle s'est retrouvée un peu
à la rue mais ok mais j'ai plus de temps
hayatou reprend à 6 c'est tout je me
prends joue encore de partout là ok on
ressort avec le galion b5
s'il faut il va reprendre sa encore je
me fais raser hockey qui arrive en déca
tu fais n'importe quoi
ah j'ai plus de temps qu'est ce que
c'est que cette merde
j'espère qu'ils prendront eux cinq jeux
préparés d'un échec
qu'est ce que c'est que cette merde
ok mais ça va aller mais c'était
vraiment la bruche et laborieux de chez
laborieux
j'ai vraiment fait de la grosse grosse
grosse merde en fait
comment elle cherche un nouvel
adversaire mais ça va on remonte pas mal
aujourd'hui je pensais que ça se
passerait pas très bien et puis
finalement on joue pas si mal que ça
alors miss tango prend les adversaires
au hasard on prend pas spécialement des
joueurs titrés pour n'importe qui
d'ailleurs ça peut être déjà retiré qui
joue anonymement aussi un tout à fait
possible mais ok alors à jouer une
petite une petite ce qu'en dit hashtag
team ce qu'en dit
ça va j'ai été j'ai trois parents qui
m'embête le plus j'aime pas trop loin de
songer qu'attache ktk relief 4 ça ça ne
dérange pas trop
d'aucuns jugent ces six dames c'est
cette foulée 6 il n'y a pas vraiment de
bonnes découvertes pour le cas mal ici
et il peut venir prendre un f6 est
doublé les pions mais c'est pas grave en
fait on a quand même une structure tout
à fait est tout à fait correct c'est pas
grave dans les pionts doublé on veut
faire food et six au prochain
éventuellement aux cavaliers 17 food et
6 ou elf 5 même à un moment donné on se
fout décider peut-être cavalier e 4 mais
bon peut-être prendre quatre ans l'âge
de vrais noms affaires food & cie ce
qu'est ce qui fait qu'il ya eu quatre on
va faire un truc que j'aime pas trop
faire d'habitude on va aller chercher le
matos bon ok mais s'ils donnent un pion
je prends
il menace d'en fermer la dame avec fief
4 nom revient ok je comprends qu'il ait
donné le pion et qui sait peut-être pas
énorme énorme et tout mais bon 17 vous
faire grand rouquin tout bêtement et
karen b 6 cavale des cinq puis commencer
à les jouer sur ces cases bondam beketch
pas du tout convaincu donc un vrai grand
rock'n perdu pas mal de temps avec son
roi
un v6 de preuve envers damas un qu'on va
faire voit ici il sait rien
allez je sais que vous aimez le beau jeu
on va pas perdre de temps ça s'y prend à
sète on va prendre deux-trois on va
ramener la dame en g3 et voir ce qui se
passe je sais que vous aimez le beau jeu
longtemps empêché au roi de revenir et
on veut faire 5 pour venir tout ouvrir
c'est sur le saint qui fera peut-être
que des saints qui me fera peut-être le
catch est pas en ouvre tout on s'en fout
quelques 5 des 5 c'est son idée c'est
clair
mais moi je sais que vous aimez le beau
jeu
reprise d'un mais chez moi ici bon est
prise la norme hockey enfin gervasi fait
des 5 alors pas se casser la tête nous
prend on prend et puis après on voit ça
va falloir qu'on fait dames c'est simple
qui on vient là il prend des cinq ans
qu'elle fait échec si froid c'est cet
effet damas cinq échecs froide et 8
du coup droit est cachée front des 5 et
de 4
comme ça je mens d'alger cinq échecs et
dame prend des 5 et 6 prend 2,4 je
prends et j'ouvre tout son sens quand
vous avez un roi au centre en face il
faut ouvrir la position du coup là c'est
ce qu'on fait on veut juste faire puis
on prend avec troyes et tours 8 1 vous
savez on est assez basique basique
bah je suis pas un génie enfin tout ce
que je verse et j'en ressens le louvre
c'est sa différence le bon choix un
dossier qu'elle voulait jour de chaque
jour et chaque mois un jour en haussant
le bon il ou mais servait joueurs le bon
joueur d'échecs ce niveau à au centre il
ouvre mais mais c'est un bon joueur
j'ai envie de vous faire le beau jeu à
fond et faire pions prendre j'ai peur de
d'am-dam ici en fait
et du coup sûr tour échec qui peut me
faire un contre échec et mat quasi
mais ce qu'il n'a pas un père pète cette
soudure dans les pionts francs f3 dame b
j'ai ça
je reprends v7 ça roy ses huit dames à
6.5
je sais pas j'ai une intuition pour ce
coup là non mais ces deux là mais on va
prendre là
on va aller se barrer et que le roi on a
perdu trop de temps à vouloir faire le
beau jeu là fichiers
on se barre
j'ai un peu peur évidemment mais j'ai
l'impression qu'on va pouvoir couvrir
avec la tour ronde et six dans tous les
cas en fait
ok je pense c'est une grosse erreur de
prendre ça et il a les trois pions pas
ça et on a plus de temps aussi
c'est un autre problème
c'est pas mal d'erreurs pas pourquoi je
fais ce coup de merde qui avait ramené
le fou
c'est le commentaire
râler la tour en 1 4
ok c'est nickel
il faut qu'on aille mater a bloqué on le
fait tomber je pense boum
bon ok c'est mérité on l'a fait tomber
soit été oubliés on était complètement
gagnant allez revient miss tango djobi
djoba jeu chansons jeux vidéo bateliers
de la tuque a lancé trois peut-être à
l'esa est une nouvelle règle quand tu es
idiot oui jo pas par hasard tu obligé de
mettre le cas lancé 3 même si ce n'est
pas envie dans les gants vidame parce
que je déteste faire ça mais ok je me
suis pris la règle de jeu mise au banc
en pleine face donc complètement
nouvelle les gens ne la connaissent pas
encore
il faut ke simple
djobi djoba hockey un peu chier tout ça
mais 40 le fou en b 5 auquel je
comprends pas trop si je prends là et
que je prends là en fait
miles a pu quand même bien
je déteste ma position c'est une horreur
si on va prendre ici on va reprendre ici
mais je déteste que je suis en train de
faire
qui m'empêche de roquet
je suis tellement en pls de toute façon
je vais enfermé sa tour je mette la dame
en d2 et je vais faire grand roque quand
même je t'emmerde peut-être pas dire ici
à damas trois mais dans l'esprit est là
je vais faire car ait lieu car pour
échanger les dames c'est ramon idc
qu'avait lieu 4 je suis de te partout
quoi ok je te fait cavalier catch de
marque dessus comme ça je te fait une
découverte dans ta gueule et je protège
ma dame ok c'est qu'ils gagnent du
matériel mais au moins j'ai changé les
dames suis très heureux
j'hésite même à rien lui donner en fait
je vais lui faire pions francs et
surtout reprend je vais faire roi des
huns dégage avec ta tour il va faire
tout france extracteur me qu'est-ce que
je suis débile
qu'est-ce que je suis stupide c'est
abusé mais ça va ça tient georges est
pas du tout reprend ses cinq noms mais
alors quoi
qu'ils ont à faire re 2 il va venir
mettre sa tour en c2 je vais faire f3
voilà ça c'était prévu comme ça sont
cavale ils s'approchent pas et auquel tu
mettes matour en b1 il peut pas venir
doubler sur la deuxième et je vais
pousser comme un idiot c'est pas très
fin mai
je vais leur en d3 d'affaires qui a aidé
5 gb 4 alain c'est la tour ces trois
échecs mais comment tu vois pas des
trucs comme ça non mais kiev en c3 échec
c'est lourd
annonçant le style coup relou strict sur
bkc à tour ces trois tout le temps en
fait un moment qu'ils ont à faire
crisser cas du coup
why not
assurément quand même fait vraiment trop
n'importe quoi dans cette partie
jusqu'ici
l'armée j'ai fait trop importe quoi dans
cette partie
je pousse le pion mais je suis sûr que
c'est très mauvais
je suis allé j'ai juste pas vu en fait
enfin j'ai rien vu en fait fin j'aurais
jamais fait roi des trois ilets vu ça je
suis vraiment très très nul qui menace
assez pénible
j'ai même pas si c'est encore
je vais pousser comme un idiot mais sans
conviction
sans conviction du tout
ok je fais maths est forcément là
quelque part c'est sûr ok mérité parce
qu'on n'a rien vu mais bon ce fait 1h20
de jeu déjà
et du coup c'est pas évident ça fait pas
mal de mauvaises partir et ça là
franchement c'est abusé je joue vraiment
très mal en fait je vois vraiment pas de
pas pas les choses clairement
et quand même juste en plaçant les
pièces bien vous voyez qu'on peut
réussir à s'en sortir
tu aurais fait refouler car quand même
je vois pas vraiment l'intérêt de leurs
mille fois en d3 plus tôt quand je te
pensée cats que du coup en fait quand il
vient ici il va les changer bon
car en fait les dessins comme soit
utilisé le clouage
donc on va venir prendre on va faire
renaître la dame ans et 7
pour aller attaquer un peu ce truc là en
fait c'est en h2 du coup si fait j'ai
trois affaires russie sous des six
cavaliers 17
le beau jeu serait de faire dame pranger
3 nantes ont plongé à sa marche pas ce
qui a foulé fin on n'y a pas de beau jeu
cette fois ci a pas le beau jeu
nok et du coup va simplement rocqué
rockets os x 5 mois juste faire b61
c'est pas très grave comme un
affaiblissement est bon ok on va bosser
il a commis beaucoup de pions sur noir
et qu'après il peut venir échanger les
fous de cases noires mais bon il est
trop grande et 4 pour le moment
peut-être hyérois fois six échecs
du coup il peut venir échanger sa et
maître laurent b 8 de soissons va pas
initié cet échange s'il veut échanger
lac à venir le faire lui-même
ok on est là tous rangs 17 temps des
huit ans a doublé
donc on va doubler quand même si venir
initier les changes qu'il le fasse
lui-même nouvelle fois même chose
c'est justement bessette ce que je veux
faire tout reprendre des cats et surtout
reprend des cats je voulais avoir
d'emprunt de 500 prend tout reprendre et
8 échecs donc qui est fait c'est 3
elle est menacé saddam en fait on va les
forcer à échanger du coup
ok puis sûr j'aurais peut-être seront un
test fait un peu trop on a peut-être
fait un peu n'importe quoi l'intro jouer
pour gagner dans une pollution n'était
pas forcément mieux alors on va
continuer à envoyer du lourd de façon à
faire plaisir est ce plus grand temps de
stream peut-être la dernière partie du
coup moi je dis faut envoyer du fonds
envoyés du pâté on lui envoie les pions
sur le roy on le met en pls et on va se
coucher on va faire b4 va tout lui
envoyer dessus en fait
bekkat sur la gueule
j'envoie tout ce que j'ai boum cavaliers
ses trois échecs dégage
on est des chats ces gens ne savaient
pas le we are 400 that you know you you
are watching catherine nous sommes des
chats vous le piège le piège qui te
tombe dessus tant peu plus tu dégages je
suis dégagé tu dégages complètement
hanter en pls thaïs les biens prisme
ok je suis ma passion est restée tout
reprendre des quatre surprise crise
prises prise
vous trouvez qu'elle prend des 1 et
tours prend des quatre manches c'est
plutôt qu'elle prendrait en premier et
peut-être c'est simple non non il ya ces
5 comment je le vois pas faire ton prend
des quatre en premier quelle horreur
quelle horreur quelle horreur non non
non non non au nom mais comment je suis
débile
en plus je vois juste après avoir joué
non non non non non non c'est juste
tellement idiot
c'est juste tellement idiot je suis trop
dégouté je suis trop dégoûté
comment est ce que j'ai publié ce
truc-là hyper simple alors quelle
catastrophe juste on prend des quatre
premiers c'est juste fini direct hall
alors alors alors
c'est juste beaucoup trop idiot
et en plus je like the light de partout
arrête de lag et ça m'énerve
non c'est débile comme coup il ya deux
points 4 allez on va jouer le beau jeu
et se faire mater qui enferme tout
qui est on va gagner quand même mais
franchement
[Musique]
franchement à se poser des questions sur
le tri du ciel on en fait une dernière
comment être aussi débiles en voit
dernières parties comment être aussi
débile c'est hallucinant a laissé la
dernière et après on ferme
alors je vais pas finir même si je perds
c'est pas grave je ne jouais pas finir
sur un truc aussi aussi ridicule
c'est trop ridicule joue aussi mal c'est
quand même un scan bénigne
affaire fou g3
en fait qu'un mot si mal c'est quand
même un poil too much
et quand même des limites à la lui à la
nullité mes limites que nous avons
dépassés à l'est avec le point 5
alors on peut s'amuser jouer dans
l'esprit à fond chassez ces pièces
inquiets france a en premier et jaillit
du prendre ça comme ça je pense que
remèdes sont cavagnan f7 mais je passe
sur ce soit grave
bon ok je fais fouet f1 c'est le beau
jeu de façon je fais sans arrêt le bon
jeu sur d'arâches 4g g3 et d'un rêve de
s'y prend angers 3 et 6 fait qu alger
cinq jeux ferrache 4,4 et je pense c'est
le beau jeu pascal ok on arrange toutes
nos pièces on n'a qu'une seule pièce
développer en fait si j'ai presque envie
de faire d'âme des uns mais bon je peux
pas
la moquée du coup à prendre on va faire
ça et sur sarfaraz th3 s'en défend la
case f2 on a quand même une pièce de
plus ce qu'est il a des pions à une
pièce de plus le faire quand même d'amd
de au prochain
on va protéger notre truc quand même on
va faire dam des deux dames j'ai cinq
mois
j'aimerais lui saisir espèces cadas va
ça va sauver ce pont soit la soie pour
rafraîchir des pantalons quoi j'ai envie
de dire sinon t'es mal ok va faire tout
reprend et on va lui faire j'ai quatre
peut-être au non j'ai pas le temps de
faire des cavs pour lui en permission to
knock on a juste fait roi ou trois ou
même tour f1 on va faire tout reste un
messie g4 c'était peut-être le beau jeu
quand j'ai quatre c'est le beau jeu
c'est pas bon mais c'est joli et est un
peu obligé de faire ça du coup on va
peut-être prendre une fois j'ai envie de
remettre un échec et j'ai envie de faire
g5 et jeuland si la finale ce que dans
la finale en fait
ok mais je faire cavale à et j'apprends
le truc et je veux venir la violence
comme la fine avec lecavalier en fait
mais je pense qu'elle doit gagner
puisque par marc peut-être prendre 2g
mais non mais papa va pas me mettre un
amas de pions c'est pas possible
non je suis trop bien tous ses pions ne
peuvent pas passer sera possible et du
coup je vais te rendais 4
et jusqu'où tour f 5 ha non ok il veut
pas faire la tour aycelin ok ok je vais
être là tous rangs des mythes du coup
et mais il veut peut-être le faire un
amas d'options à ya sanction qui passe
et il menace maths en plus ils sont si
on va à dame oh la la
les champions va à dame oulala c'était
super bien joué de sa part et ben fini
sur un beau truc parce que je n'avais
pas du tout vu du coup c'est une belle
feinte c'est forcément gagnant pour moi
mais j'ai pas vu ce truc là et là il à
dammaj 4 maintenant ok ils le voient pas
du coup je survis mais waouh c'est assez
joli la fin n'est pas assez concentré et
j'aurais dû jouer deux mers plus simple
avec juste au rêve si ça a laissé
d'encaisser son pion et du cou et du
confiture une jolie défaite on va vendre
et c'est très joli et en fait après je
pouvais plus rien faire de neuf mois
sont très très beau très joli parce
qu'en fait ils menacent ou re 4 matt est
dit qu on est rentré à cette variante
c'est un très joli piège
du coup je mais il fallait juste faire
un truc comme tour f6 en fait ce que je
voulais faire de base
je veux comme quoi je n'ai pas fait en
fait j'ai pas juste faire tous
réussissent à la base était complètement
finie j'ai eu halluciné sur le truc
comme tour penchée 5 ou quoi ça gagner
direct bon merci d'avoir suivi et à
bientôt ciao ciao